[Music]
before we get started let's take a quick
look at the evolution of the cloud
landscape I know that this has been the
buzzword so to speak since the last
several years now if you if you look
here you'll see that as we started this
migration to the cloud it started out in
a bunch of different flavors so there
were you know combinations of hybrid
cloud which is you know part on-premise
and then part of your workloads residing
in the cloud then there were also public
cloud there was private cloud of course
due to security and other reasons there
were a lot of enterprise companies that
that preferred starting out their cloud
journey with a private cloud instead of
a public cloud but what we can see here
is that over the last three years of all
of these different combinations that we
just talked about the public cloud is
the only one that's been growing so
we've been seeing an increasing trend of
enterprises wanting to move more and
more of their workloads to the cloud
we'll be talking about you know some of
the benefits of course but in general at
a high level this is of course because
of the the flexibility that a public
cloud brings to the fore so you don't
really have to worry about the the
management aspect of it you don't have
to worry about things like scaling up
scaling down Scylla or disaster recovery
things like that and as we evolve we
expect to see more enterprises wanting
to leverage these capabilities that are
all provided by public clouds if we take
another step in in this direction again
we're looking at the industry trends
here you'll see that the top couple of
reasons or the top couple of projects
that enterprises are really investing in
are optimizing that existing cloud use
right so this is you know companies that
have already invested in the public
cloud to some extent but they just want
to optimize more again this may be for
cost savings or you know other
motivations as well and then there are
companies that are starting to move more
and more of their workloads to the cloud
databases of course are very central to
cloud migrations but as you know they're
also really tough
this is due to a number of different
reasons right so we're gonna take apart
maybe a couple of the top reasons the
first one is of course there's a lot of
proprietary technology and functionality
that's built into a lot of the legacy
database technologies right so if we if
we talk about Oracle I'm just using that
as a frame of reference here that may be
things like stored procedure custom
functions Oracle RAC so on and so forth
so this makes it really hard for you to
migrate to an equivalent cloud native
technology the second one is of course
your your historical on-prem databases
are all pretty monolithic so these are
humongous servers which don't really fit
into the cloud way of doing things right
so oftentimes again if you take this
huge monolithic server you have to split
it up into multiple servers in the cloud
and the third thing which a lot of
companies actually maybe underestimate
is the reliance of applications on
databases right so as if you think about
a company that's that's been around for
you know let's say 10 15 years as your
business grows you have like hundreds or
thousands of apps both internal and
external facing applications that are
all relying on the database right so as
you're thinking about migration it's
really important for you to consider the
risks that are associated as you're
migrating these two different cloud
native technologies and obviously trying
to you know minimize your exposure as
you do this so because of all of these
complexities that we talked about we see
two general types of database migrations
right so there's homogeneous migration
which is you know also commonly known as
lift and shift where you're retaining
the same database engine but you're just
moving over from on-premise to the cloud
while this does bring some benefits like
for example you know you're you already
have like a trained up staff that
understands the technology that's really
familiar with it and so the there's not
as much of a learning curve associated
with it as you're migrating the stack
over to the cloud so that by that by
itself extends into faster migration
time as well and like I said in this
case because the database engine is
still this
same you have fewer application rewrites
which of course means that in some cases
you might have lower risk now that being
said there are also some challenges that
we briefly talked about in the previous
slide which is you know server sizing
and configuration like I said if you're
talking about huge monolithic servers
moving this to an equivalent way in the
cloud is going to be really tough so you
have to think about how you can you know
split up this huge server into multiple
different servers the other type of
migration is called heterogeneous
migration you know people commonly also
use this in the same vein as
modernization or digital transformation
which is essentially saying that okay I
want to port over my database engine
I've already invested a lot in these
licenses and you know the cost of
maintaining those licenses is actually
going up with every passing year and as
my business grows I'm actually building
a lot more applications on top of that
so what that means is that you're saying
that okay I'm going to make a business
decision to invest more in the cloud and
I'm going to do what I need to do to
actually make it fit into the cloud way
of doing things now some of the benefits
for this you know we commonly see you
know cost savings or you know lowering
or TCO is one huge thing that we see the
second thing is also reducing your your
reliance on a particular particular
technology as we've seen the evolution
of public cloud there are more and more
open source based technologies so so we
will talk about Postgres today and a
little bit about my sequel as well and
we see this across the database spectrum
not just in the relational world but a
lot in the non relational world as well
so by moving to these technologies
you're actually lowering your reliance
on a particular vendor as well as the
proprietary technology that comes from
that particular vendor and then of
course because you are in the cloud it
makes it a lot easy for you to you know
scale up and down as needed so that you
don't have to have like reserved
capacity at all times so if you're a
retailer who is you know who's thinking
about you know peak season times like
you know Black Friday sales or Christmas
holidays or something like that you
don't really need to you know hold on to
that capacity for the rest of the year
you can scale up and down as needed and
you don't
have to worry about about that the other
thing is of course you know failover and
disaster recovery instead of you know
investing in your own data center and
maintaining them all around the year you
can actually offload that to the cloud
provider right and as we move into the
cloud way of architecting our
applications of course more and more
companies want to just take care of the
innovation piece right the the things
that truly help you derive business
insight and value instead of things like
how do I manage my infrastructure how do
I manage my database how do I configure
this they don't really want to get into
the business of doing that and they
would rather have the the public cloud
provider take care of that of course
some challenges with this it's it's
going to be a more complex probably
longer migration effort and when you're
you're moving from one database
technology to another one you also have
to be mindful of things like schema
conversion another thing that we talked
about was you know if especially if
you're talking about production grade
applications you have to make sure that
there's no data loss right so that's
where your real time change data capture
comes into play making sure that you
know you're able to migrate your data in
real time instead of doing it in batches
right so these are the challenges that
we typically see so now I'll hand it
over to David to take us through the key
steps that are involved in any database
migration and then we will get into the
details specifically from you know
migrating your databases from Oracle to
Postgres thank you so every database
migration project is complicated
specifically when it comes to heat
Eugenia's database migrations because as
Kavita mentioned there are challenges
which we can overcome but our challenges
and what you see here is kinda like
taking a database migration project and
breaking it down to I would say the six
primary steps and we're going to go
through each one of them talk about some
of the I would say areas that you should
be made aware of some of the tips and
recommendations we can share from our
experience as I said we have done you
know countless a heterogeneous database
migrations both on permanent primer and
of
obviously on-prem to the cloud so we
would love to share this experience with
you
so let's go over the steps starting with
assessment and source discovery so this
is extremely important because it's the
first step in your database migration
journey you need to start by
understanding what you currently have in
your existing environment specifically
you know this talk is about Oracle to
Postgres migrations to cloud sequel post
based migration but this is also
applicable when you change database
engines from other source and target
technologies understanding the source
environment what you currently have
running right now the layout and
structure of your Oracle databases
before you even start the migration
might seem like trivial but it's super
important and that's because a lot of
the features which you may be using
right now in your Oracle database your
high availability configuration you may
be using Oracle RAC or data guard you
might be using some proprietary features
so you need to be made aware of these
before you start your migration so you
can plan to mitigate any I would say
functionality that might be missing in
Postgres that you've caught using an
oracle by leveraging other google cloud
technologies and we'll see some examples
of that or sometimes even by writing
custom application code so that's the
first thing that you need to do when it
comes to database assessment in my end
migration you also need to be able to
determine when you do your migrations to
Google Cloud and specifically when you
choose cloud native database
technologies such as Postgres and/or my
sequel you also need to make a decision
which database engine is better for you
that's because a lot of the
functionality that you may have sorry
just a skip the slide a lot of the
functionality that you may have in your
source Oracle database might only be
available in my signal or Postgres and
we're going to talk about that as well
as well as so some tools and products
and tips that can help you make the
right decision so assessment and source
discovery is very important you'll need
to review your database configuration
your schema your database sizing is
kavita said very large
monolithic databases might need special
attention when it comes to migrations
you need to make sure and see if you're
using any proprietary features you need
to take a look at your database workload
because some of your because as you know
applications which were developed to run
on an Oracle database might use some
Oracle specific sequel syntax or even
when it comes to if your all of your
applications support other database
engines such as Postgres your workload
behave differently so performance tuning
is also an aspect and we're going to
talk all about that but assessment and
source discovery is extremely extremely
important also as shown on the slide you
have to understand what applications
connect your database because when you
move in appliqué database to the cloud
you're saying you know what I'm going to
move my Oracle database to cloud sequel
pause because for example you need to
make sure you understand which
applications connect the database can
this application be post-party to
Postgres maybe they are compatible with
Postgres if you have legacy applications
it's going to be a much more challenging
migration process than if your
applications are relatively Morden
so the assessment and and source
discovery is very very very important
and there are there are two ways to
actually do that so the old-fashioned
way of kind of figuring out what you
have running right now you might have a
CMDB database somewhere but drilling
down to the actual databases
understanding what are the features that
you have the correct configuration and
what high availability infrastructure
you have in place you can either do it
by running scripts you know sequel
scripts and and you have a bunch of like
code that you can run on the database to
detect what are the features are using
you know you can query the oracle data
dictionary for like understanding what
what schema object to use you can query
the oracle aw re+ understand what's the
workload running in the database but we
also want to talk about the product that
we have developed as I said we've been
doing these database migrations for a
long period of time which kind of takes
all of our experience and puts it in a
pin a product that can automate the
assessment and discovery for you and
that's me advisor which you're going to
show you a demo
mcbowser for google cloud which we are
officially launching today is a custom
made product built for Google Cloud
which can scan your existing Oracle
environment and help you create your
migration plan show you what databases
you have running their configuration the
proprietary features show you the
migration complexity for both Postgres
and my sequel running in DCP and you'll
see it will still live them which i
think is very cool but that's a we think
at least that's the reason we created me
advisor it's a much faster way and a
better way to start off your migration
journey instead of having to do
everything manually and as I mentioned
previously it's also extremely important
when you start your migration before you
actually and we'll talk about in the in
the next steps in the migration process
but before you start converting your
schema and moving your data and kind of
notice I actually implementing the
migration itself you have to choose
between you know if you're going to
leverage cloud native technologies if
you're going to leverage Google Cloud
sequel if you're gonna leverage open
source database engine you have to
choose between posters in my cycle which
again depending on the specific
proprietary Oracle features you're using
the types of schema objects that you'll
have pour squares or my sequel might be
a better fit and again our product
mcbowser can help you make that death
decision and as you'll see in a moment
but again this is an important step you
have to take take into account in
addition to the you know sort structure
of your source database and the
compatibility of certain schema objects
you also have to kind of take into
account if your IT staff is more
familiar with process for my sequel
these are like the non-technical
requirements but they're also very
important and also your applications so
if you're moving your database and its
application to GCP you're going to
leverage cloud sequel posters for
example but the applications that's run
on this database right now happen to be
I don't know support both Oracle and my
sequel so maybe my sequel will be the
better option so also you have to take
that into account as you start planning
your migration journey so there are on
the technical aspects of choosing
between postcodes and my sequin again
this talk is mostly focused on posters
but it's still something that's
important kind of to mention so there as
I said there are schema objects that you
might be using right now in Oracle or
features that you might be using right
now in your Oracle database that are
supported in either my
sickle and Portsmouth you see some
examples here such as sequences which
are only supporting Postgres
user-defined types which are supported
for stress but virtual columns on the
other hand have better supporting my
sequel partitions for example no post
quest n as is there is the first version
of phosphorus that added declarative
partitioning support post res 11 expands
on that but my sequel always had a
partitioning mechanism that's more
closely that closely resembles what you
originally had in Oracle so there are
differences okay and it's very important
to kind of keep that in mind and this is
just like a few of them there are a
bunch more and again we're going to show
you in the me vizor demo how it can help
you how our product can help you
identify those features and kind of tell
you hey so this database might be better
suited to run on cloud sequel Postgres
well that database might be more
compatible with cloud sequel my sequel
so I can just keep that in mind as you
kind of start your migration journey so
Mike visor for Google cloud which again
we are watching today is main is meant
to automate your source target discovery
and assessment phase it detects your
database configuration your schema
configuration the schema object that you
are using it gives you like an overview
of hey this is your existing Oracle
fleet these are the proprietary features
that you're using these are the schema
object that you're using and then
assigns a migration compatibility score
migration complexity score to both cloud
sequel my sequel and cloud sequel
Postgres as well as by the way if you
just plan to run Postgres on a compute
engine so there are also differences
there which we'll talk about in a moment
so it meant to automate this process and
kind of give you in a very visual way a
lot of insights and metrics and
dashboards that are relevant for a
migration process before you even start
migrating a single database which is
again super important you know you don't
want to start a migration and then you
know as you as you go through it and
kind of realize oh wow we forgot that
this application connects to the
database once a quarter to run a report
and it's not compatible with Foursquare
so that's like puts a stick in our
Wiggles or oh wow we have so many
synonyms we have like over a hundred
thousand synonyms in our database which
we have seen databases that have such
excessive number of synonyms and that's
not supported in Posca so what do we do
should you create like views
is workaround so all of that is kind of
like presented in divisor our product
has two components so it has the web
console
it's a SAS product so you have the web
console you see all of our migration
insights all of the details about your
environment environment so you can
explore and see how your migrations
gonna look like and also we have a very
small standalone component known as the
McVeigh sir metadata collector which is
a standalone java utility you need to
download and run it on s server in your
existing environment it can even be your
laptop you do not need to install it on
the database itself our metadata
collector what it basically does is
connects opens a JDBC connection to
existing fleet of Oracle databases it
can connect to thousands of data bases
in one go so it it supports like you
know analyzing your databases in
parallel runs a bunch of queries queries
the Oracle data dictionary queries the
Oracle
you know meth-addicted tables the oracle
awr repository gathers all of the
information that's needed for the
migration analysis and then creates a
local zip file encrypted which you
upload to our console and then boom you
see all of the migration inside so
that's kind of the architecture for our
product and we created it so it would be
extremely easy and simple to use again
you don't need to install anything on
your source databases
you only need one metadata collector no
matter how many Oracle databases you
want to analyze and we see you know our
users when they want to analyze your
Oracle environment for cloud sequel
migrations for GCP migrations we see
them being able to from start to end
from actually being able to access the
migration insight it's a matter of
minutes okay and traditionally if you
were to do this using scripts and like
running and creating like spreadsheets
and war documents kind of mapping your
existing environment and trying to
figure out which application connects to
what database and what are the
complexities it would obviously take
much longer than that sometimes you know
if days minimum sometimes even weeks for
a large fleet of Oracle databases so
before the demo just a couple of a few
other slides I want to talk to you about
so essentially all of our migration
insights all of our metrics everything
that we kind of show and surface in
mcbowser it all boils down to a
migration score
so we basically give each database in
your requirement to score from zero to
100 depending on how complex it is so I
just want to show you a couple of
examples of two examples of how the
low-complexity database for migration
would look like versus a highly complex
T database and you'll see more in the
live demo so for example we have an EZ
migration database they're an easy data
base to migrate so this is an Oracle
database that has of course some
proprietary features it has some no
Oracle specific schema objects make
sense I mean it would be rare to see a
production Oracle database that does
just as a bunch of tables and indexes
right right
so the features that we detected in this
database such as you know job scheduler
inter region data guard you know certain
you know tables and data types some
functional stored procedures indexes all
of those aspects have compatibility with
say Postgres as a target platform so the
migrations code below and would even
when we kind of show you our migration
insights will even give you tips what we
call migration tips on hey you're using
Oracle jobscheduler to maybe run jobs in
your database you know I can already
occurring basis there are alternatives
you can use so we're going to show you
to maybe use Apache airflow for example
so you're going to show you that in our
products as well so it's very cool and
again this is just an example of a low
complexity database we also look by the
way at the stored procedure code and
kind of trying to figure out if you have
any usage of proprietary Oracle DBMS
packages UTL packages certain sequel
syntax that might be only compatible
with Oracle such as a connect by
expression which might not be supported
fully so again very easy database to
migrate on the other hand there will
also be databases which would be more
difficult you know in a big Oracle
environment you'll see a mix of low
complexity and high complexity databases
that is expected but you want to be made
aware of that beforehand and maybe
that's how you can prioritize which
databases you're going to move to cloud
native open source technologies and
which database you might want to you
know do as a lift and shift project so
here is a more complex complex database
so it's a rack database which would
require a architecting your database for
deployment because you're using an
active active cluster
it has a lot of data machines so you can
have like you know multiple stored
procedures or sequel queries where
you're in manually influencing the
behavior of the Oracle optimizer so that
would probably indicate that performance
tuning when you move to Postgres we fix
query planner which would probably run
those sequels differently would require
a big effort so that's another thing you
need to keep in mind
it has synonyms which does not which are
not supporting Postgres but we will tell
you hey maybe move these two views
migrate them two views it has user
directories so you're probably accessing
files from the operating system from
within the database so that would
require again maybe moving to Google
storage database links same so what
you're going to do you're currently have
this Oracle database accessing other
Oracle databases so you need to keep
that in mind maybe you cannot move this
database in vacuum and you need to maybe
move a bunch of databases together and
again usage of DBMS in UTL propriety
Oracle pet pack API is inside your store
procedures multiple partition tables
some of them might be like you know hash
partitioning which is not supported only
supporting post 11 if I'm correctly fast
refresh materials view is complex
queries so again just an example of how
would a high complexity database for
migration would look like and the
benefit is that you will be able to
determine if you have multiple Oracle
databases where which are the ones are
going to be the quick wins the
low-hanging fruits the one you can get
maybe move to migrating to cloud sequel
Pospisil my sequel relatively easily so
let's maybe do a quick demo of our
product just to show you make virus or
in live action so if you can switch to
my computer please that would be
fantastic
there we go so that this is our login
screen again it's a SAS product when you
log in the first thing we show you is a
high-level overview of record
environment such as how many database
has have you actually analyze using
advisor this is just like a very small
demo environment the server sizing
number of CPU cores we also show you the
comparative migration complexity here
you can see for running phosphorus on
compute vs. cloud sequel possible vs.
cloud sequel my sequel we also show you
again like depending on the target that
you choose a very high-level overview of
like this
quick complexity per database but we do
surface a lot more details this is just
like a high-level overview of your
existing environments you will know what
you're dealing with before you you know
dig deeper and then I think the coolest
feature is that you can actually
simulate your migration before you
actually perform it so say we're
interested in moving oracle to cloud
sequel you know Postgres you know that's
that's what we're interested in so we
choose the source and target combination
we click on analyze then you can choose
you know some of all of our database
server click on analyze and the first
screen we see it's a very high-level
screen that even if you're not a
database administrator and you just you
have no no database background what we
do is rank your databases based on
migration complexity from lowest to
highest so without even digging deeper
which we'll see in a second I know that
I have databases where the migration
complexity is going to be very low so
maybe here is my POC here is my product
database for heterogeneous migration
versus other databases where it's going
to be more complicated so it doesn't
mean that we cannot migrate them it just
means it's probably going to be a more
challenging process it's often
worthwhile but just you know surfacing
that those details beforehand clicking
on each one of those databases that's
where you start to select the verbose
information so each one of those bars is
of course clickable and we can also kind
of show all of the databases that in one
screen and then we actually this is
where we present all of the individual
features that we have detected in each
one of the source databases that can
make your migration easy or more
difficult we also show you some server
related information for sizing here here
are all the features that we have
detected so this is for example a record
database it has a hundred and three
database scenes and it'll show you like
the schema name and the actual you know
procedure name or where we found the
database scenes it has over a thousand
synonyms and so and as you see our list
of the features that we detect which is
over a hundred different features in
Oracle is quite extensive and we also
flag those features based on the
migration impact you know high medium
and low so it also takes into account
the number of usages for a feature so
it's not just hey we found
usage of Oracle's dbms random package
it's because we found only one usage of
it so even if you have to manually code
an equivalent for DBMS random or use
like the course quest equivalent it's
not going to be that difficult but if
this was like I know a thousand
occurrences then it might be a little
bit more difficult and we also provide
those migration tool tips so when you
click on this little eye icon next to
next to each one of the features that we
detect we show you a small short and to
the point tool tip of saying why is this
why was this feature flagged
is it gonna be a problem yes or no how
how can you work around anything that's
not supported and you also provide links
to the actual cloud cycle documentation
so for example for synonyms you'll see
clicking on it will just say hey so
synonyms were detected however they are
not supported you can use views or maybe
the set search path in your queries as a
workaround and again we try to provide
this information for each one of the
features that we detect provide multiple
alternatives if possible just so you'll
know that before you actually start your
migration we also provide the ability to
do schema based analysis so you can
exclude certain schemas from your
migration analysis let's see want to
peel off individual schemas and move
them to two GCP we also kind of help you
perform target sizing so we show you the
memory i/o and CPU requirement for its
schema which can be again very useful
because we see a use case where people
take these monolithic oracle databases
and break them up split them up to
smaller cloud sequel instances we also
show you a list of all of the
applications that connect to the
database thus we won't forget any
application you know when you do the
migration if there is this reporting
tool that connects you know once in a
quarter but generates a report for a co
super critical but that's I know it said
legacy application written in Oracle
Hyperion bi
something that's not compatible with you
know more modern cloud native
technologies you want to be made aware
of that we also show you do a workload
analysis on the database showing you on
a schema level and per instance level is
this not all TP database in analytics
database the ratio between all type in
analytics queries per schema maybe
bigquery would be a better alternative
for certain schemas where the workload
is predominantly analytics so we show
you this
we kind of surface that we also show you
database links schema dependencies so
again all of this information is meant
for you to understand what you're
dealing with before you actually start
your migration process we also flag OCI
applications that connect to the
database so that you'll know if your
application mix is modern or legacy and
again we encourage you to use some
advisor for disappea is going to be made
available in the marketplace soon right
now if you want to use it you can reach
out to Kavita and we do encourage you to
use an advisor for Google cloud is the
first step in your migration process we
think it's very valuable and can save
you a lot of time and and you know kinda
we try to just take you know our
experience and kind of from database
migrations and kind of turn that into a
product so let's make Weiser if you can
please maybe switch back to the to the
deck there we go so that's database
assessment for you again it's the first
step and we encourage you to put effort
into it so that you will basically know
what you're dealing with before actually
start the migration process itself the
second step is you know success criteria
so might seem like trivial but it's
actually very very important there are
multiple steps when you actually start
migrating your database converting your
database there are multiple steps you
have to take into account you have to
make sure that all of your schema
objects were converted successfully you
need to plan for functionality testing
so you move your database you convert
your schema we will talk about schema
conversion in a moment you want to run a
representative test of your applications
of your current application workload on
on the target database to see that
nothing breaks right you want to make
sure you plan for data validation so as
you move your data from your on-prem
environment to your cloud sequel you
want to make sure that all of the data
has been replicated successful and we'll
talk about these steps in a moment it's
just like understanding what you need to
do for you to be successful and planning
for that you'll need to do performance
testing even if your applications are
fully compatible with Postgres right
just switching the JDBC driver and
everything would run fine you're only
using NC sequel syntax so no propriety
Oracle joint syntax or all up functions
or none of that stuff even with all of
that the queries will behave differently
different data bases different up query
optimizer the execution plans will
change and queries that might have
behaved in a certain way may be using in
might suddenly switch to full table
scans right so you have to make sure you
plan for performance testing as well
it's super important you have to do also
plan for integration testing so as I
mentioned a database is not in vacuum
doesn't exist in vacuum because in
addition to the application you might
have dependencies on other databases or
other technologies in your organization
using Oracle database things or
application tier integration API is that
need to kind of you know query multiple
database at the same time so you have to
plan to make those tests as well and
again the same tests that you have to do
on the database level you also have to
do that for the application so unit
testing performance testing integration
testing again and plan for all of that
that's your success criteria for for a
migration right here the next step would
be to actually you know start you know
getting your fingers dirty and actually
starting doing the migration itself
well that normally starts from the
environment setup so you have to create
the target environment in GCP that means
that you have to first convert your
schema and that's that's a hot potato
because we can detect them using
mcbowser for example a lot of
proprietary features you're using we can
surface those details we can give you
tips on what you have to do but you'll
still need to actually perform the
migration so you have to leverage
different api's convert your stored
procedures convert from your material
materialized views for example your
partition tables all of that stuff now
there are tools such as aura to PG which
is an open source tool that can help you
automate a lot of the schema conversion
process right depending on the
complexity of the source database the
success rate from our experience go
anywhere from like 30 40 percent
automation convert automatic conversion
to sometimes even 60 and 70 percent but
it's never 100% so for the schema
conversion piece leverage automatic
tools such as auto PG but you'll also
need to put some elbow grease into it
you have to put some manual you know
honest DBA work to kind of convert some
of the more trickier schema objects some
of the more trickier stored procedures
so that's schema conversion okay it's
part of your environment setup before
you move the data before you test your
application you need to make sure you
have a fully converted source schema the
second aspect is well you'll have to
classical target so you have to
understand what's the configure what's
the sizing that you want your cloud
sequel target to be comprised of so how
many CPU cores how many how much memory
right was the isle ahrefs requirement if
you're breaking one Oracle database to
multiple cloud sequel instances you also
have to keep that in mind so you have to
size intelligently that's what we always
say and you can reference I would say
that's as a tip reference the workload
you have on your Oracle database and not
the physical hardware configuration as
your baseline that's because you know
cloud economics for scaling is are
different from on-premise economics and
we see a lot of times we have this big
monolithic Oracle databases running on
which have been over deployed so an
organization bought like a very high-end
you know super capable like like server
with like hundreds of CPU cores
terabytes of memory just in case because
they know that they might need to scale
up they know that they might need like
room to grow in the future so they have
over provisioned ok not all of the
database are like that but many are and
because it's very easy to scale up when
when you kind of move to cloud native
technologies we would encourage you
based on our experience to look at your
actual workloads such as the number of
active sessions in your database instead
of physical CPU cores the actual
physical reads from your storage tier
instead of the eye ops and throughput
capacity of your I don't know like
NetApp or storage machine in your
organization so base your sizing on
workload and again we try to kind of
show this information some of it at
least in the advisor as well and then
you also deploy your actual you know
Google Cloud targets which includes say
cloud sequel for Postgres for the
database but also compute engines VMs
for your applications because you know
you're gonna test your applications they
need a you know virtual machine to run
so you also have to kind of do that as
part of your environment set up when it
comes to schema conversion again I've
kind of talked about it in a previous
slide but some tidbits here when it
comes to moving your different database
object that you might have in your
current schema right now from Oracle to
Postgres some of the challenges and
you'll have access to this slide so to
this deck so you can kind of reference
that later but
exactly no object identifier so Oracle
basically if you're using quote
identifiers it converts it to uppercase
and porce let's convert them to
lowercase so this can break your
sequel's unless quote right but we see
quoted identifiers in a lot of the
queries generated by certain
applications so that's one thing that
can kind of cause pain when it comes to
schema migrations database links which
we talked about so Postgres has an
extension for under the wrapper that can
give you equivalent database link
functionality in the database right
that's not supporting the cloud sequel
right now so you have to keep that in
mind maybe for certain databases that
are heavily relying on database links
you might be better off with pause
Poisson compute engine or moving some of
that logic to the application tier again
a partition tables so podcast 9 has some
limited does not have declarative
partitioning support it only provides
table inheritance which is not
equivalent what Oracle does is
partitioning Postgres then adds the
support for table partitioning some of
the Oracle partition types not not all
of them
Postgres 11 expands that a bit a bit
further but again keep that in mind
sequences so you move your database
sequence values will have to be
recreated so you might have sequences
right now that have you know have like
their values of sequence a might be at
the value of 10000 sequence B might be
currently at the value of 256 thousand
and 91 so when you create the sequences
in the target you have to make sure that
you actually when it comes to the
switchover you resync your sequences you
invent them manually to their current
state in the source Oracle database
again these are just some of the
challenges you have to keep in mind even
when you're doing a lot of this schema
conversion using tools such as or 2pg
there is stuff that you'll have to do
manually triggers are also different
right so a trigger in Oracle is both the
event invoker as well as the logic so
you created a trigger on a table the
trigger will actually fire once when you
insert a row for example once per row
and it also contains the logic in
Postgres is different you have the
trigger itself which calls a function so
again just kind of keep that in mind
some other aspects again I don't want to
go to all of that that's a lot of the
nitty-gritty
but there are aspects when it comes to
schema conversion environment setup that
you have to kind of take into account by
the way this is all kind of surfaced in
our product but it's also thought it
would be nice to show some of
bigger challenges in the slide acts such
as using viewers instead of virtual
columns local temporary tables instead
of global temporary tables temporary
table behavior is different so keep that
in mind as well
reverse key indexes are not supported
beatmap indexes are not supported
synonyms you have to use use instead so
again keep all of that in my digital
migration there are data type
differences again this is like it's
boring it's literally stuff but keep
that in mind not all data types are
supported as is even Oracle lobs if you
move them to the byte their data type in
Postgres it has a one gigabyte
limitation require API changes so again
keep that in mind and it's very now you
see why it's important to kind of
surface all of those details before at
least start migrating because you know
we want to choose maybe for the first
database to move to cloud sequel you
wanna choose a database that's I would
say easier to migrate they're not
necessarily your most complicated
database in organization some other
stuff such as you know certain changes
in like how you invoke functions certain
changes in the sequel dialect you'll
have access to this to this deck just
some tips you know lesson learns from
for migrations we have previously done
but again it's kinda like just kind of
surfacing the challenges when it comes
to to schema migrations a couple of
things about stored procedures and want
to mention briefly so Postgres eleven
sorry process versions nine and ten only
provide functions instead of packages
and stored procedures that's that's a
challenge you have to create it again
your great function instead of sort
procedures for Swiss eleven finally has
a create procedure statement right so
that's super cool however invoking
functions and procedures are different
so you need to change that syntax in
your application and packages are not
supported so you need to use schemas in
Postgres to group certain procedures or
functions together certain oracle pl/sql
control elements are also not supported
so again a lot of stuff to take in we
don't have time for all of that but just
keep that in mind when you do the schema
conversion and again reference you know
this deck and you can use our product
for some other information that could be
conceived a lot of pain in the future so
post Chris eleven
prospects ten in eleven also brings a
lot of improvements when it comes to
Oracle competitor
versus puskás 9.6 such as enhancements
of parallel queries again this is a very
nice slide I can like cherry-picked some
of the features which I think are more
most applicable when it comes to
migrations can actually pick those and
put them in one slide so you can have it
as a reference because Postgres 1011
they have a lot of functionality some of
it is is specifically relevant for
Oracle to post post migration so
enhancements in parallel queries such as
polymer join such as part
index candies of things that the Oracle
optimizer knows how to do and now
post-it notes have to do them as well
we have full-text search support for
Jason and Jason B data types we have
additional performance enhancements by
the way enforcing leaven such as
paralized hash joints so pre important
covering indexes finally right so that's
another post post eleven features you
can use a create procedure which is a
new syntax not available previous to
that and you can call using the call
syntax to invoke stored procedures in
your database but again have the slide
as a reference keep in mind that posts
10 and 11 bring a lot of new
functionality that's more equivalent for
what you might have right now in your
Oracle environment ok and when you
finalize all the schema conversion
aspects automatic and manual and you
want to deploy your cloud sequel
instance super easy like few clicks in
the Google Cloud console UI you can
provision a cloud sequel instance up to
64 cores and four hundred and sixteen
gigabytes of memory which by the way
that's the limit for you so if you have
an Oracle database that has more is that
you need more than 64 cores or 416 gigs
of memory you will probably need you
know to split up this database and its
workload to multiple smaller you know
cloud sequel instances in DCP if you're
migrating Oracle RAC it's going to be a
challenge right there is no way to do
active active clustering in GCP right
now in cutting process at all by the way
it's not just like specific to DCP
but there are workarounds around that
such as moving some of that logic into
the data access layer into the
application tier itself so that you can
actually maybe have like a fleet of
Postgres cloud sequel databases ready
and then you can do the hot swap swap
via the
application here you can also maybe kind
of send application requests using AK
you like it such as Google pub/sub so
that you know the data access layer can
I can it in caso failover take those
requests and route them to the cloud
sequel instance that will become
available throughout there are some
workarounds about that as well
oracle data guard is going to be a bit
easier to migrate you can use post post
replication which is natively supported
in cloud sequel there are some
challenges such as cross region dr if
you're doing that right now but again
it's much easier so rack is going to be
tricky requires some application changes
if you want to make the same levels of
hive availability data guards a bit
easier but again keep that in mind that
still needs to kind of you need to lab
you need to know how to leverage the
right cloud sequel technologies to do
that you need to test for failed for a
failover so before you actually you know
sign off on the new environment you have
to test failover so once you provision
everything once you have your
replication set up once you have your
high availability set up you have to
test failover before you move your
production workload you have to see that
it behaves as you expect it to behave
you have to test your backups you have
to test your you know how long it takes
to recover your database so all of and
you have to of course configure
monitoring and alerting this is all part
of the environment setup and again it's
super super super important other steps
now I'm not going to go into like the
net then the next few steps a I don't
have a lot of time but B there are other
talks at next which cover these aspects
there is a great talk from Illume about
data replication specifically just want
to briefly mention that so data
migration so as to provision your
classical target converted the schema
you know it's going to be a challenge
right you still need to take care of
moving your data copying your data from
your Oracle database to the cloud to
Postgres there are a lot of tools that
do he true genius data replication right
so you can either use like a bunch of
like ETL tools that are available you
know informatica for example you might
be using like Pentaho or talent or
clover ETL there are a lot of some open
source or commercial tools that can help
you move your data right but you also
need to understand the concept of CDC
data replication which is change data
capture so if using ETL tool to move
your data that's a
one time copy and that would require
downtime when moving your data from your
existing oracle environment to ports
quest because you move the data but data
keeps changing if people keep working on
your source Oracle database data keeps
changing so you will lose data on the
switchover and that's why I tools that
perform like real-time CDC change data
capture Connect they read the Oracle
review logs and they stream the
transactions to the target in real-time
are often used when you want to minimize
downtime heck many of you might be using
products such as Oracle GoldenGate right
now which is hit a hit Regina's database
replication product from Oracle you can
leverage that to move data to
Portsmouth's for example so there are a
lot of tools out there and there are
there are there is a great Illuma talk
about data replication you know ethnics
which I encourage you to attend but then
again keep in mind that the differences
between one-time loads and real-time
replication so again I talked about it
in previous slides I'm not going to
iterate but you need to make sure that
you take into account both floating what
you currently have in your database as
well as kind of how you're going to plan
and stream changes to the target you'll
need to test your applications we talked
about it a couple of points I want to
mention so you have to stress test your
existing database your saw your new
cloud sequel database and see that it
meets your performance characteristics
you need to make sure that your
application workloads SLA is in terms of
like query performance and query
responsiveness are met okay we talked
about it essentially but that's stuff
you have to do only after you migrated
the data so only after you have like a
working copy of you know cloud sequel
process for example with your data and
the compute engine servers to for
running your applications that's what
you can kind of like test your
applications so that's again Sam you
have to do and also keep in mind that it
might be worthwhile to create a reverse
replication flow so in case you have to
do a rollback so let's say you planned
everything you executed everything
everything is great you know but then
after you went live you found out an
issue maybe an application you did end
up forgetting so you'll need to kind of
think about creating a reverse
replication flow just in case you want
to roll back your changes and move back
to the original Oracle database and
really work things out because otherwise
if you just set up a one-way replication
process and you move to a new possible
target and you start working with the
changes apply to post quests would not
be replicated back to Oracle and it will
essentially be lost when you switch if
you if you need to switch back let's
hope it won't happen but Sam Simon might
happen so again we talked about all of
that it's in this in the deck I don't
have a lot of time so I'm gonna go
briefly over that but again we talked
about that and it's in the deck for
reference so do application QA make sure
your application behaves behave as
expected right nothing breaks and
performance is good do query QA and
database QA right both on your on the
workload side but also making sure that
you can failover that you can backup and
restore the time it takes to back up and
restore so you'll know your IT is you
know set up as as as you need it so we
test high availability to test dr you
allocate time for performance thinning
this is all part of the migration
validation step compatibility of
application we talked about it some
modern applications might be more
compatible with Foursquare's legacy
application might not be as compatible
so it's very important to map the
applications that connect your database
right now are there legacy are there
modern are using the oracle call
interface custom drivers JDBC ODBC you
know Java applications would probably be
easier to port versus I know C++ or I
don't know like COBOL applications have
some some of the legacy stuff so you
need to make sure that your applications
are compatible it's also sometimes there
is a difference between porting in-house
applications to third-party applications
so if it's an application you developed
in-house you might have the resources
internally to make the changes needed to
support I don't post press or my sequel
if needed if it's a third-party
application you know may be and it's not
supported then that's going to be a
problem right so map your applications
for compatibility and identify
specifically legacy applications that
you know would probably make sure your
migration a whole lot more complicated
we talked about performance bottom line
switching database engines queries will
behave differently no matter how
compatible you are and how much you
think that you're only using n size
equals so plan for performance use
testing as well we talked about robic
strategy just a bit right so create a
reverse replication for flow for your
data migration making sure changes are
applied back to the source database I'm
sorry and you know keep your environment
after you go live with the new
environment keep the old environment
around for at least you know a few days
maybe a few weeks just in case maybe you
forgot with the script running on the
chrome tab of the Oracle database that
you forgot about right so just keep it
around because you might you might need
it
again this is like rudimentary stuff but
we saw a project where you know people
went live close the old environment and
then you know figure out that they
missed something
[Music]